عند مشاهدتك لها لاول مره ستظن ان هذه
السفينه تغرق او ربما نوع من انواع
الغواصه لكن العجيب في الامر انها تحاول
ان تقف راسيا في المياه فبينما يتشبث
هؤلاء بثقتهم في تكنولوجيا هذه السفينه
الغريبه يغوص اغلب جسمها في اعماق المياه
السفينه فليب القلابه مملوكه لمكتب البحث
البحري الامريكي تبحر في المياه لاغراض
بحثيه فقط منها مراقبه الطقس وتاثيره على
المحيط وارتفاع الامواج ودرجه حراره
المياه وكثافتها كما تبحث في الصوتيات
وعلم المحيطات ومراقبه الثدييات البحريه
منصه ادوات فليب فلوتينج ليست سفينه عاديه
لكنها منصه ابحاث بطول 355 قدما يمكن
نشرها للبحوث الاقيانوغرافيه اي علم
المحيطات تم تصميم فليب من قبل العلماء في
مختبر سكربس للفيزياء البحريه ويتم
تشغيلها بواسطه سكربس اوشينوغرافي للبحريه
الامريكيه
عاده ما ترسوا سفينه فليب مع اسطول سكريبس
في خليج سان دييغو ولا تبحر بمفردها بل
يتم قطرها في المياه الى الموقع المعني
فسفليب ليس لديها محركات وعندما تصل لموقع
البحث مراد يتم قلبها بزاويه 90 درجه يظهر
راسها ويغرق غيرها المكون من ثمانيه
صهاريج لتملا هذه الصهاريج الموجوده في
الذيل بالمياه والمقدمه بالهواء حينئذ
يتغير مركز الثقل ويبدا الذيل في الانغمار
والمقدمه في الارتفاع
استطاعت السفينه القلابه اتمام 300 عمليه
بحث بنجاح منذ بدء تشغيلها في عام
1962 وهيعتزن قرابه السبع مئه طن ويبلغ
طوله حوالي 180 مترا يغمر منها نحو 91
مترا خلال الابحاث وهو ما يساعد على ثبات
السفينه ومقاومتها للامواج وما يظهر منها
هو راسها فقط البالغ طوله 17 مترا بارتفاع
مبنى من خمس طوابق
عند تحولها من الوضع الافقي الى العمودي
تستغرق حوالي 28 دقيقه فقط ولكي تغتص لابد
من امتلاء خزاناتها الضخمه بالمياه تحميل
السفينه فليب فريقا بحثيا مكونا من 11
باحثا وطاقم المكونا من خمسه افراد
عند عمليه انقلاب السفينه يذهب كل الطاقم
الى السطح ويستلقي على الارض في مكان مخصص
ويقومون بتامين وتثبيت انفسهم حتى تصبح
الارض هي الحائط السفينه مو صممه بما يضمن
للمشغلين والباحثين العيش عليها بسهوله
لدرجه ان الاسره والحمامات والموقد مثبته
على محور حركي بمقدار تسعينات درجه
التقنيه بهذه السفينه متطوره جدا لدرجه
انها تستطيع دراسه حركه الامواج الداخليه
في حوالي كيلومتر مكعب من المحيط العلوي
بطريقه فريده للغايه كما ان لديها القدره
على استمرار عمليات البحث لمده تصل الى 30
يوما دون اعاده الامداد
[موسيقى]